hi everybody thank you for joining this
pydata global 2021 workshop i'll keep it
brief i've just done some of the basic
housekeeping before i started this
recording i'd like to introduce nabanita
roy who's going to give us a great
workshop on getting started with text
analysis now benita i'll hand over to
you straight away okay
thanks kevin um everyone uh welcome to
this tutorial on text classification
um in this tutorial we'll be looking at
how to predict uh if a tweet is about
natural disasters
um before i start a little bit about
myself i
my name is nabanita roy and i am a data
scientist at eci worldwide
i um really like natural language
processing and and i really play with
these kind of techniques so here i am
with this tutorial on getting started
with text classification um we're going
to look at supervised classification
only in this tutorial
and so um
let's begin
so in our agenda today the first thing
that i'm going to do is run through this
powerpoint presentation which which lays
down the basics of uh text
classification and text analytics um and
after that uh when we look into the
notebook we will be using python you'll
find uh the python libraries which are
required for
today's workshop uh
lying down in requirements.txt
in the in the
github repository that i've posted there
and here's the list once again
if you want it
keep um before
we begin you could
start installing them
in the workshop we will look a little
bit about data set uh this is a bit of a
tricky data set because this is um about
tweets and uh tweet texts are a little
bit tricky in terms of text processing
hunt analysis
and we'll see why i will look at some um
basic exploratory data analysis some
text pre-processing techniques then we
will be training a binary classifier and
then we will we will be looking at
some model evaluation techniques for
classification tasks
so uh let's begin with the basic
question here what is natural language
and what is natural language processing
uh natural language is anything that we
talk uh write or express as a human and
leveraging the modern technologies for
processing this uh
these uh expressions uh
the expressions that we do as humans is
natural language processing and
and nlp where does it fit in the ei
ecosystem um
natural language processing is
essentially an interdisciplinary subject
wherein um
uh disciplines like a computer science
uh technologies mathematics statistics
and
you would require
expert
knowledge of the computational
linguistics and
behavioral sciences so all these
different domains come together and form
uh the national language processing
domain so it's um fairly
interdisciplinary in nature
there could be
essentially when you think about a
natural language processing task
in an industrial setting you might want
to accomplish a technology goal and in a
research perspective you want to achieve
cognitive goals so
technological goals um mostly are
when you want a machine to do something
like
text extraction for um
analyzing social media for
uh say indicators of real disasters like
what we're gonna do now uh maybe look at
uh some reviews on amazon and um as a
company as amazon might want to see what
is the what is the general response um
to a particular product that they're
selling
on their website so these are fairly
achievable using um our latest
technologies
a little bit more advanced version of
natural language processing applications
is making um a machine work or listener
act like humans so
what happens is uh because
um our styles are so different so
at even me as an individual i would i
would
text on whatsapp in a different way or i
would write an article or even when i'm
talking right now it is a different
style
and um
the whole um
the the entire thing if we want to uh we
want a machine to work like a human uh
that whole objective becomes a bit more
complicated so it's a bit more difficult
to achieve
so
in this workshop we will be definitely
looking at a simple technological goal
of just text classification using
supervised machine learning
so what is
um
text classification
um and what is supervised machine
learning so
uh
text documents can come
um
you might want to uh
look at text documents on the internet
and you might uh be able to as humans
understand if they have if they're
for example if you look at sentiment
analysis if they're positive or negative
in nature if you're looking at news
article you might understand if it's
about um is is it like um
about politics is it about business or
finance or is it about sports
so um
we as humans can do it intuitively but
when you want to train a machine to do
that sort of job where you've got
different categories and you want to
have a collection of text documents
categorized into these different uh
labels
that is called text classification and
using supervised machine learning means
that you already let the machine know
that um
what these um what um
a text is about already so you let the
machine know so if you if you're
categorizing news articles you let the
machine know that some of these texts
are politics some of these texts are
about business and some of these sports
are about
sports and after you've trained the
machine learning model based on the news
articles that the model has seen before
it tries to
um
predict if an unseen text document that
the model
that's a text that the model has not
seen before
um
is about politics or is about business
or is it about sports
uh the other um example goes as
if an email is a spam or not you might
see um in gmail uh
some of the emails they they
automatically get classified as spam
so that's one of the most common use
cases of text classification
um every time an email comes in uh an
algorithm determines effects if it's a
spam or not
um
gender identification if uh if an
article has been written by a male or a
female person uh sentiment analysis
again um a very uh
famous um and widely uh used application
of text classification using supervised
machine learning
um and
it looks at uh user reviews and user
sentiment and it has been um
really essential um component in a
marketing industry
so when you when you talk about text
classification one of the um important
things that we look at that we talk
about um as a term is called target or a
label
so
um
the the
the keys that you give a model to
understand what that news article is
about or if if if a review is positive
or negative
so those uh those are called targets um
the the
the information that you provide if it's
positive or negative ones or zeros um
politics or business or
um
sports so
uh for gender identification a label
would be male or female for email it
could be a spam or not spam so these are
that is um the word target only or label
is going to be used repetitively
in this tutorial
um so let's begin with some text
processing techniques um today
so uh we will be looking at rejects and
text extraction so the the the most
elementary form of uh extracting
information from texts is rejects which
stands for regular expressions um
essentially you match a pattern with a
text and you want to extract um
a text that occurs
according to that pattern
sometimes you want to find just find
them and process them in a different way
sometimes you want to substitute them uh
these the the text which matches a
pattern and sometimes you just um you
want to use them for new features
so regex is one of the uh most
elementary ways uh even it could be used
for tokenizations uh where you match a
pattern saying that for every the num
the letters which are occurring in
between uh two spaces uh extract those
words and those are uh the words that
are occurring in a sentence
so that brings us to tokenizations
tokenization is is a method in which uh
you you break down a whole uh corpus um
so by corpus i mean a collection of text
documents
um
so if you want to analyze them you would
really want to get hold of the basic
units that for that that are words or
tokens and breaking down a whole corpus
into these uh simple units
of words
is called tokenization
uh
once you do tokenization there are few
other pre-processing that needs to be
done
so for example you have to do case
conversion
case conversion is like uh you want to
convert
in the entire text into lowercase or
uppercase that's for ease of uh
preprocessing for example if you say
so
just in case uh just if you want to take
the example of tokenization capital t
tokenization and if i've written down a
paragraph about tokenization that
paragraph might contain small t
tokenization
and when a machine learning algorithm
looks at these different cased
words it'll uh it'll consider capital t
tokenization as a different word than
small t tokenization so case conversion
is essential unless you're working on a
particular use case in which that in
which the capital uh
or the sentence case is essential
then there will be noise because you're
getting these um
these texts from
the internet or
somebody's handwritten text if if those
are the things you're scraping you're
scraping data from different languages
so it might contain accents it might
contain html tags
and it might also contain symbols emojis
from tweets
uh so these things needs to be removed
and checked for
um contractions so often when we write
down um in conversations even in uh
standard literature books if you want to
process uh
bookish texts
then
you will find i'll i i've or it's
um
these kind of words and these are called
contractions you might have to expand
those contractions into i will i have it
is
uh stop words so stop words are words
like r is the which occurs um multiple
times or
probably the most number of times in a
document
uh but they do not contain uh essential
information a lot so these are called
stopped words
and uh you and you would mainly look for
uh removing those uh analyzing and
removing them
right
then normalizations the normalization of
text processing techniques for example
for converting these
for different versions of verbs
so for example if you've got visited or
visiting or visitor
and you want to just get hold of that
the root form of that word um you might
want to use some normalization
techniques so there's stemming and
limitization um
stemming is a crude uh rule-based
approach for getting um
for removing prefixes and suffixes and
just getting the rule word uh root word
uh from a word
um
and
limitization is a little bit more
advanced which takes a few more semantic
um and syntactic uh
um
[Music]
information from the words for example
parts of speech so it understands if
it's if a token that you've passed in is
is known as a verb or an adverb
and um
it processes it and gets the root form
of that word and this is mainly for
standardizing all the different
variations of uh of the same word that
occurs in english language or any other
language
parts of speech tagging and named entity
recognition are text dagger mechanisms
in which you want to tag if it if a word
is um is noun or a work or an adverb or
an objective
um and named enter recognition is also
important uh to understand if a text
contains um a name of a person
um if it contains the location we will
be looking at these um few um and ner
so in abbreviations called ner so some
of those um
named entities in our tweet as well um
you might also want to detect if there's
any amount like financial amounts uh
dollar 200 if
if it's written down somewhere you want
to extract that information so you can
do that using integer recognition uh you
can extract dates
um
and etc
so
these are different uh text processing
techniques uh not limited to uh there
are many more uh different kinds of
those um but these are the basics and we
will be looking at most of these in our
tutorial
and this is a little bit of an example
of how the tokenization and cleaning
works so if you see the first sentence
there i just saw barack obama in
oh
i think i missed uh in over there so i
just see barack obama so i changed the
cases for uh barack obama um to lower
case and um
all all the elements in the sentence
please uh don't consider in over there
so i just saw barack obama they were all
separate into uh five different um
uh tokens or words
uh in the next example you see this this
one contains some html tags say the p
and p here it contains an emoji and it
contains a um
a symbol there and contains an accented
character so you might want to
convert this into
a series of tokens like this which will
contain i will say i have expanded the
the contraction here as i will see you
soon monsieur
and um
[Music]
yeah and i converted the saw here to c
so that's again for standardizing for
normalizing um a text
word
so
from here so these are all about the
basics of text
processing so we come to
machine learning part of it um so
if you're from machine learning
background you would know that machine
learning learns everything from numbers
machine learning is essentially
statistical models and you need to
represent everything that you have in
text into numbers and um that's
essentially what we're going to do after
doing all these pre-processing we're
going to take this bunch of numbers uh
sorry we're going to take this bunch of
texts and we want to throw them and
pre-process them and trans convert them
all into a series of numbers
um
for for a machine learning model
uh
to comprehend
out of it
so how do we do that how can we
represent texts into
um
in into numbers so the the most basic
form of it is just counting the number
of words
the terms that are occurring frequently
so that model is called bag of words and
a bag of words model does not um take
into consideration the position of the
word in the corpus
but it only takes the frequency um in
which a token is um appearing in the
text
so um
the word bag here refers to refers to
the uh to an unordered list of words so
the order is ignored essentially
and uh it also allows multiple
occurrences for getting it counted so
if this is a pictorial representation of
how this little text is converted into
an unordered list over here and it
contains different words it occurs
multiple times and if you
line them up here count these
these vectors um
if you want to count these
numbers here you find uh the number of
times
um the words say 8 i 32 and they have
occurred so many different um
multiple number of times and if you
notice these are all the stop words
which do not contain a lot of
information
it um
these are the words that we need to
remove uh later on and um
most say for example you want to see
whimsical times sweet historical
adventure genre
fairy i think uh these indicate as um
as like it is about a movie or a drama
or a book so
uh
if you if you might consider why you
might consider that uh if a word is
occurring multiple times that doesn't
mean that um
that word
necessarily contains a lot of
information
so that's the backup word models where
you represent
a text into
the number of times a particular token
or word is is
appearing
in the text
uh the other model here is called a bag
of words model and
the this model takes into account if um
if how many times uh
the number of tokens appearing in a
sequence so unigrams are essentially
just taking the individual tokens
for bi-grams it's taking two at a time
so this is is a sentence so when you're
looking at count vectorizer so this
appears once is appears once
appears once and then disappears once
and this is also pure spawn and if there
is in the entire corpus any other in any
other collection of sentences so this is
august again the count for this is is
going to be two so you take two of the
sequences sequentially appearing text at
once
um and count the number of times uh
these two tokens have occurred
sequentially in uh in the entire corpus
and then get the count of those
um and the last model that we will
discuss is the tfidf model tf uh tf idf
stands for term frequency inverted
document frequency so term frequency is
essentially counting the number of uh
times the words occur
but um a drawback of that model is that
it gives more importance to the tokens
or words that appear more number of
times which is like we've seen which is
not necessarily the ones
that contain a lot of information
so tf idf model uh what it does it
penalizes uh words which occur multiple
number of times and it and it takes into
account how many times the token appears
in one document and also in all the
documents so it kind of normalizes the
effect of um
of the words which are appearing
multiple number of times
so
um yeah i just think maybe it was like
stuff for a few quick questions there we
don't sponsor through those three models
so
if anybody has any questions there um
uh so i think there are a few questions
here on the chat
okay i don't see any but hey go for them
if you see them there
okay
oh yeah right right
so i see this uh do you have uh you
can't see the screen or the video stream
if that's an issue over there
i
don't know if that's applies to everyone
because i'm watching it fine so uh so
okay probably uh that that participant
maybe just log out and log in again
maybe that's the best thing you could
say
so uh i have a question from tom how
does how does it work for languages
other than english which keep words the
same and relies on other on word orders
some other languages the irish or polish
modify the words quite a bit from the
basic form so this model
so there are other models which do take
the sequence in a consideration but this
model so like i said the limitation of
this model is um it doesn't take the
order and sequence in consideration so
um
uh
if you apply this you should be knowing
that
this is this is not going to take uh the
sequence in
order for other language even for
english um
i think
uh
even for english the order is
an important factor i don't know which
language um for which
uh a sequence would not be a factor
um
say irish or polish i'm sure if you're
speaking then they they would have
uh
some sort of
they would have sequence whatever
language we speak so uh
these are these are addressed in other
advanced models in which the order is
considered and they're mostly um in deep
learning or neural networks which
consider them and that is out of school
for this tutorial
unfortunately
um and given how emojis are pervasive in
everyday writing now should we not make
efforts to capture them so we do not use
information yes we should capture so
this depends on what your uh
what um use case you're working on so if
they're like tweets or um
from social media then yes uh
it's definitely worth processing those
emojis
and um they're they're different
libraries which are there
nowadays i
i think
i think it's straightforward as emoji uh
some python library that does it for you
and um
it depends on
how much effort you want to give into
processing these techniques so because
they they require a lot of computational
power
so uh it's for you to decide what you
want to keep and what you want to delete
from there so you might want to treat it
as noise if they're not very important
for the use case you're solving so for
example what target or what label are
you trying to predict if those for
example sentiment analysis for them
uh i would suggest you you that keep the
emojis they're very essential for it
but something like uh you know
classifying uh what
uh a tweet is about
in general what did you tweet is about
in those cases i don't think uh having
emojis would be much helpful so in in
those cases you can treat it as noise
i think there's a couple of questions
there keep going so yeah
all right
cool
all right
um
so yeah so in the statistical models the
tf idf um
model is is it does take into
consideration the drawback of
um of account vectorizer or
the back of words model
so when you when you start working on
the tutorial in python you will be
addressing that as
a count vectorizer because that's that's
um vectorizing the texts um into
uh the counts of the
the counts of their appearances
and tf idf essentially normalizes them
and uh it tones down the importance of
the words which occur multiple times or
most number of times and also
um
the the words which which appear less
very less frequently and it boosts up
the
importance of the words which have
medium counts
so the last part of this presentation is
model evaluation for text classification
so when you've got these labels um for
example um
if you've got um
sentiment uh you might have you might
label them as negative and positive
so the actual data set will have some
texts which contain negative
i'll take the questions after i
talk about this yeah sorry
so in uh sentiment um
in sentiment analysis use case so uh for
example we'll have something some of
those texts which are positive some of
the texts which are negative and that
that is what um
the
machine learning algorithm will be
trained on
and the ones uh and then there will be a
predictive prediction set
in which um text will be labeled by the
model and uh we'll have um
an already existing set of labels on
which we will be comparing the
prediction predicted labels and saying
that okay so it was supposed to be sent
it was supposed to be positive and the
model predicted it as positive so that's
a true positive that's that means that
the model has been able to to label a
text that has that had positive
sentiment correctly
and um similarly a for negative
sentiment now uh the problem comes in
when a positive has been misclassified
into a negative sentiment one or um a
when a pause when a negative sentiment
has been classified into a positive
sentence uh sentiment one
so uh this this little chart that you
have on on the right hand side this is
called a confusion matrix and it
summarizes the number so it compares
between the actual labels and the
predicted labels from the model and that
is based on the test set of the machine
learning uh use case
where the model has not seen the actual
labels and it's predicting on those
unseen texts and you get these um the
true um
you get
and you get this um the numbers in here
on depending on those numbers you will
be uh
getting uh the accuracy precision uh
recall nf1 score out of these um
of the model and these are these numbers
are going to help you to evaluate uh how
good your classifier or how good your
model is
so
looking at curiosities accuracy is
pretty simple uh out of all the samples
how many of those samples were correctly
classified by
the machine learning model so that's as
straightforward as that uh
accuracy can be tricky sometimes so
sometimes the number of
if you're taking the example of
sentiment analysis sometimes the total
number of texts in the training set will
not have um as many instances as
negative sentiments so for example in a
data set if you have 1000 samples of um
positive sentiment and 500 samples of
negative sentiment that's like 50
percent less and the model learns from
it and it learns that
and so the probability of of labeling
something negative uh
diminishes
before the training itself right
so um that's called an imbalanced data
set where the labels are not balanced
enough so uh if there are 1000 positive
samples it should at least have some 800
900 negative samples or 700 uh negative
samples at least
and only then the the model will be able
to learn from almost equal number of
samples now if when you're evaluating
them using accuracy
um
sometimes uh it's called accuracy
paradox and um
accuracy will not be the uh best
solution for um evaluating that sort of
data set
uh model's performance on on that kind
of data set because
most of the times either it'll at the
the true or negatives will fall so
it'll be nearly equal to one most of the
time
because um the
uh that either the true positives or the
true negatives are going to be almost
equal to the number of the uh to the
number um for all samples
uh and for us in this use case we will
not be
encountering that
um so we just kept kept it fairly simple
so the next ones would be precision and
recall and these are looking at only the
positive classifications
or just one set of classification
so
precision is uh how many times
so precision is all about models
prediction and how precise the model has
been in detecting
uh the true positives among all the
positives um
that has been predicted by the model so
amongst all the positives that has been
predicted predicted by the model how
many of them are actually positive
and recall is all about uh what are the
number of
number of positive instances that has
been correctly predicted out of all
those which are in
which are actually positives
so
in in this chart you can see
precision is
all about the predictions
so
uh the true positives divided by the the
sum of true positives and false
positives so precision and for recall
um true positive divided by false
negative and the true positive for
recall um
and it's all about the actuals
and f1 score is basically getting the
best out of the precision and recoil and
it's the harmonic mean of these two uh
um these two metrics and uh it kind of
gives an overall picture of how well the
model has performed in terms of the
actuals and in terms of the predictions
uh made by the model
so um
i can
um
go back to the questions once and we can
start uh you uh with the python notebook
now
yeah like i said that so the ones which
are occurring very so that was that
example that i have on bag of words is
really small
so in a large corpus what happens is
these numbers blow up
really high and the numbers which do not
occur much they they do not those are
those are also the ones which do not
carry much information so this is based
on just a little snippet but when you
add more and more information in those
cases you will find that words like
whimsicals satirical adventure genre
which actually uh as a human as well if
i see this i'll be like okay this might
be about a movie or a drama
and in those texts where got more and
more information these words might have
uh such sort of an an average count of
um
uh of uh count
average numbers of counts
right and the ones like the stop words
will have many occurrences and the words
they will not have any information and
the words which occur very less
frequently they are they would also be
the ones which will not carry a lot of
information so it's always mostly about
the counts would be
about um the average over there
if you want to line them up in the order
of comments
thanks uh for the discussion so i can
stop
the uh sharing i reshare my screen
um
and if you could all get started um with
the
tutorial if you want to follow on with
the jupiter notebook
so
once you have installed them just ensure
that all the imports are fine and we can
just start work working through the
basics of it
um
so we'll be using pandas we'll be using
scikit-learn we'll be using word cloud
and ltk and matplotlib and cbone for
plotting
um
yeah that's it
um
contractions as well okay
so um a little bit about an ltk so nltk
is natural language processing toolkit
and um
it is uh one of the basic uh python
libraries which are available out there
which has uh different
nlp techniques um
available
in its epi and uh
they're fairly straightforward to use as
well
once you've done that you might have to
download a few um
an ltk
corpus for
the word tokenized to work
um i think you'll encounter an error and
do whatever nltk dot download um
those
corpus
i don't think you would need them in
collab
right
so the first thing that we'll use is
pandas read csv we'll be reading the
data
trained.csv the data set is there in the
repository itself
and then we will be checking the data so
if you look at this um
[Music]
little uh snippet here uh you see
because these are data sets so uh this
data set is about tweets so these uh
tweets have been scraped from twitter
and they contain some html tags some
hashtags mentions it'll contain some
emojis um and symbols as well some um
punctuations some of those have been
cleaned out for us um
in the in the data set already and some
of those are still in there
uh in this uh little uh so it contains
uh five columns one is the ies those are
ids of the
um of the tweets there would be some
keywords which are present in those
texts there would be a location from
where the tweet was posted or
um the the tweet location as and how the
users have entered in the tweet
and then the target so the target saying
whether that particular so whether this
tweet is about a natural disaster or not
so one means it is about a natural
disaster real natural disaster and if
it's a zero it means it is not about a
real natural disaster um
so
this these use cases are used for uh
disaster location and disaster
identification for
um
recoveries and stuff so
um
so in this data set we have
uh seven thousand six hundred thirteen
instances and five columns as we can see
here um
so we'll be doing a few eda steps
looking at the data distributions we'll
be looking at the missing values we'll
be looking at the cardinality of the
features and the targets the cardinality
means the number of unique values
present in in a feature
so by feature i mean
i mean these id keyword location text
these are the columns that will be that
we might use for training them all so
these are all features and the target is
the target or the label for our
supervised machine learning uh use case
okay
and um
so we'll be looking for missing values
so if there are missing values then we
might have to remove those from our data
set
the number of times um what are the
unique values present in these columns
or features
um what is the distribution of the
target by keyword so which keywords
occur most for
uh say the real disasters which keywords
do not uh have a lot of information
about a lot of tweets which are about a
real disaster
the the distribution of target by
location so which locations have a
higher number of uh tweets coming in
about real disasters
so these are a few edius steps that we
will be looking at today
so the first um
the first
quote is about cardinality check so
there are a few different ways of doing
this
what i like to do is i just use a for
loop and um have and just take the
length of each of these columns in the
data frame and
apply unique on it and it gives me the
number of unique instances there so you
can easily see that there there
all the cardinalities are really high
and that is really expected because ids
should be equal to uh the number of
instances in the data set
keywords are um so the keywords could
have been of low cardinality if maybe uh
they were more uh you know clustered
together
but as you can see the keywords have 222
unique instances so these it cannot be
um so
it has higher cardinality
locations have 300
3 000 uh unique instances
texts have 7503 unique instances
and target has two unique instances so
um
what you can do is
uh so i haven't removed these um
the duplicate text from uh the
uh machine learning model but this is um
this is there in one of the future works
you can do or you can remove these
duplicates
uh
and then for because it is a binary
classification task binary
classification meaning that um you would
have only two target classes so it's
either zero or one so that's the binary
classification task if it was a
multi-uh label classification task you
might have more than two uh targets so
it could be one two one three or zero
one two
however you won't want to label it
and then just want to take a look at the
uh number of non-null values and the
data types in in the data set
and um
i see that uh
text id and target there are no no null
values whereas keyword and location have
some um
non uh some missing values and here's a
little plot to see which um
what what is the distribution of the
missing values here so i just take um
the sum of the nulls
and then divided by total length of the
data frame that is the total number of
rows and get a percentage of
uh the total uh which gets the
percentage of um
the um
the number of missing values so it seems
that uh location has a higher number of
missing values so
it's almost about
30
um
30 percent of the data set
does not contain
location information and a very s
small number of uh
percentage of keywords missing in the
data set
so uh there are two ways of handling so
missing data
missing values either you drop all of
them or you want to fill them up with
some sort of value and uh in so we will
be retaining this information and um
and we will not be dropping anything we
will see if we can find anything any way
of replacing them
and uh not the keywords though
but
uh remember because we will be using
these statistical models and we will be
looking at the number of times these uh
the words that has occurred in the text
so these keywords are a subset of the
actual text so you will find
um
say uh just a second so you will find
words like ablaze
in the data set so if ablaze was there
in the keyword
then a blaze would also occur in the
text so in those cases you basically
don't need the information that is there
in the keywords for and for
training a model using the text because
ablaze will already be
seen by the model in the in the text
column
so um
we can easily drop keywords but we want
to still uh analyze the data before we
discard it
so we will be keeping it
so you can see this word so ablaze
keyword is there and it will also be
present in the text here
so the locations you can see there are
different kinds of location here you see
just the city and there's uh
establishment uh capital letters and
that's that's not you that's like a
continent this is just a u.s city and
the state so there are different
variations they could be um
hashtags in the location which is really
messy so this this emphasizes on how
difficult natural language processing is
and especially when you're looking at
social media texts
[Music]
i just wanted to check um what's there
in it
so you find so there will be
um
urls as well in the texts
so what you might have to do so for data
analysis you might have to go and
print out different chunks of the data
and see what sort of data is appearing
and
what could be the animal is present what
sort of noise you might have to clean in
it
the next uh cell is i just uh like to
standard uh standardize the column names
so that i can just use it directly these
variables in
in my data set
so you can totally skip this um when
you're working
on your own use case but this is just
how i prefer
for my coding
so every now and then you'll see the df
if i'm selecting a keyword so i'll be
using these variables i have named here
so these are scoring practices
so the next thing is about keyword
analysis so the main questions that i'll
be addressing is which keywords have
occurred the most on which keywords have
higher percentage of tweets or
are about real disasters
and um
it sees that it seems like
uh this is also looking at the kind of
keywords that has occurred here so
fatalities have
um
the highest number of uh tweets in the
data set then deluge
and i think um fatalities and
fatal
these words are occur here so you can
see fatal here you see fatalities here
and
um so you can see that there's a problem
of normalization again so you can use
stemming on these and you can
you can
um
reassess the uh keyword counts
and then radiation emergency and
inundation thread these are uh less
frequently occurring keywords
yeah
armageddon is
uh means something about
apocalypse
and then
i have so whatever i have got there i
have again uh
created another plot
which with hue on target so
the the the argument hue basically uh
splits the data into the classes um
in
bar charts
and uh i passed and y as the keywords it
basically cut plots the the counts of
these keywords and separated by the
target labels so
zeros are
the ones which are not about real
disasters and ones are about those which
are uh real disasters and we check um
words like keywords if it's after shock
then those are not about real disasters
that's that's
um
cannot be explained but
things like debris and derailment and
there's another one called wreckage
at the bottom so all the tweets over
here you see the grace the gray bar is
missing that means there are um
no tweets uh which are not about real
disasters all the tweets which are
um all the tweets with keywords uh
wreckage
um
wreckage derailment and debris they're
all about real disasters
if you look at them
um
and then body bag so it contains a
percentage 20 so you can either so i
cleaned it uh but then later on realized
that i
it doesn't make sense to clean the
percentage 20
because i will anyway be using these
texts for
cleaning for model training
so
these are basically uh
this is a process that i've taken to see
the top 10 keywords for tweets about
real data sets
so it's uh the bar plots here
um says that derailment wreckage and
outbreak there there are the most
frequently occurring the most um
frequently occurring uh top keywords for
tweets about real disasters and it's
fairly um
uh
you can use that from the previous plot
and then again i have taken the counts
for uh
the the keywords only for about real
disasters and audit
which are not about real disasters and
uh sorted their values by um the i
the counts of the ids
same i did the same thing here so when i
passed in the data
i uh sorted those values by the id
and just took the first 10 out of it and
similarly here when i plot this i just
took the first 10 out of it
and that's my plot where body percentage
packs so they're different versions of
bodybuilders body bag this body bagging
and their body
just simple bag
no bags so those are a few cleaning
process that you can take a look at
later
on and this is just an overall
probability of um appearances of
keywords uh among um all the all the
tweets a
and probability that
if that keyword appears then would that
tweet be about a real disaster or not so
where derailment debris and wreckage
have 100 probabilities depend uh based
on the data set that we are working on
so um
so the next thing we look at is target
analysis so before we proceed into
target analysis are there any comments
there
no okay
all right so um after we look at the
keyword analysis we look at um i looked
at target analysis
so id is used as counts
it just you could use any other field
for counts but id because it's um it
doesn't have any duplicates and id is
it's just um
so um id has been used for accounts
because it's got all the unique values
and there are no null values it's just
for counting
and
the general purpose of this uh
this analysis is just to see what kind
of data set is there and
before you train a model you should know
what data you have
and this is just a sneak peek into
how you can conduct data analysis using
texts
so the next thing that is important for
training our model is
okay yeah you're grouping by and you're
counting the occurrences there and
that's why i've used ids there
uh sorry here
yeah
uh so the target so we need to see uh so
like i talked about imbalance details of
what what is the percentage of data that
what is the percentage percentage of the
tweets which are about real disasters
and what is the percentage of tweets
which are not about real disasters um
that we need to assess and here i have
um
a percentage so the 57 percent of the
data set has uh is uh about uh it's not
about real disasters whereas 42 percent
of it is
about a real disasters
so it's not that bad so we can fairly
ignore uh the problem for uh imbalanced
data sets so we don't have to really
balance the entire data
had it been really small
like uh if if if we've been like only 1
000 samples of real disasters as opposed
to uh 4 000 samples of not about real
disasters then we would have had to go
for uh balancing techniques
so we can fairly ignore that here
[Music]
and then just um by location so this is
just trying to see uh what is the
distribution of uh the target based on
the location
um
uh sorry where the target is uh within
in which location is not present so this
is just for
checking because um i i i had a thought
uh i thought about if if people are not
posting their locations uh it might be
that uh a higher percentage of tweets
are not about real disasters and that's
how what it is
seen here
even though uh tweets which are about
real disasters are catching up with it
but i would uh assume that if people are
posting about real disasters it would
have some sort of location
um
value in it
and then this translates from this one
that um yeah because anyway our data for
not about real disasters is hard than
about real disaster so it follows the
percentage distribution here as well
[Music]
uh
so the target refers to human terms is
as how
you understand
what is uh whether whether the tweet is
about a real disaster or not target is
basically
uh just that
um that understanding if it is or if
it's not the target is understanding uh
when you're predicting
if it is about a real disaster if it's
not about a real disaster
like for for sentiment it's is it is it
positive or is it negative so positive
say one and negative would say zero for
real disasters we we are labeling as the
the targets or the tweets
which are about
uh real disasters
are one and the tweets which are not
about real disasters are zero so that's
our target
zero or one
and the target is for predicting the
target will be fed to a machine learning
model from which the model will
understand when it reads a text or tweet
on
one side and it will map it with the
given target on the other side and it
will assess
the patterns which are there in um in
those in all those tweets which are
about real disasters and in all those
tweets which are not about real
disasters and it will be predicting that
target and giving a value back to us if
if it's a zero or one
based on which we will be able to
understand uh what is the
what these um what what the model has
been is predicting
i hope that makes
sense it's for us to infer from the data
set what it is about
okay
sms does account by yourself you don't
define why um right
uh it does but you need to pass in the y
or x so you need to give some sort of
value uh to uh understands which which
axis would it plot on so x and y are for
which of the axis
so here for example i've used y is equal
to target so it is for the y axis so
that that axis and this is the x axis so
whenever i use x so here in this case i
used x is equal to target so it knows
that it has to plot the count on the
y-axis and the labels of target um
on the x-axis similarly here
problem
so then uh we look at the locations here
again um and we want to see what sort of
location is present so you see all sort
of gibberish data are present you have
some latitude and longitudes got english
words like news uh in in the location so
uh it's not a very like it's not really
standard
and uh
just looking at
the um
[Music]
all those locations which are there in
real disasters
tweets about real disasters so this is a
sneak peek so this is basically for
analog just generally getting an
overview of what type of data is present
and you see there are cities and cities
state city country uh like here and
there's um country name country
abbreviations there's nothing standard
in here um so it's it's it's not that
straightforward to assess the locations
so uh
and this is the top most 20 most
frequently appearing locations in tweets
about religious disasters and this is
without
uh cleaning this
um and the reason being uh cleaning all
these is going to take a lot of time
and i think uh
you can
go
after the tutorial you can spend some
time in looking at how you could
standardize them
um
[Music]
so usa united states um so you can
create what what you can do is you can
create a whole mapping system in which
you could say that everything which is
uh which is written as usa and united
states you can put them all into one
category called usa and you can create a
dictionary about it and then map all of
these uh
different locations into it you can also
um
standardize uh the city and you can
extract
just the state names and see if they
these state names occur in the
collection of statements in the usa the
different ways of doing it but it's
going to be really time consuming
um
if you if you attempt it
so
so the way out here so when i was
looking at this so i saw that it's going
to be very difficult and time consuming
in order to do that so what i did is i
went back
and i want i did some
location tagging using named entity
recognition techniques um and i
applied that on a tweet and extracted if
um if a location is present in the
actual tweet body or not because if it's
about real disasters and i would expect
those tweets to have a location
associated with it written down in those
texts when they're when they were posted
so uh the next few things is just about
some text data
test where you will find
so this is just looking at the data and
looking at these so you find some
mentions here and uh
some gibberish data some um hashtags
over here some multiple punctuations so
we might we will have to remove
punctuations and uh remove urls from the
text uh html tags dimensions and uh
percentage menu from the keywords
um
so here uh with the basic cleanings we
go into the text pre-processing the
first element that we learned about is
uh red checks and uh using regular
expressions you can um
detect the pattern in which a string or
a text appears and you can either
extract them or substitute them so what
here so i i have used regex for
substituting so re dot sub is for
substituting input strings
um and with when um when that given
string matches with the pattern that you
have provided so here i've written down
a pattern
for uh rejects using this regex and um
i will essentially remove them i won't
have i won't keep any of those urls so i
just substitute them with a blank space
or
with nothing basically no blank space so
it'll just remove them all from the
corpus
and this is basically the input text
text string so you can play around with
this
different uh ridge axis so this is just
for testing i haven't yet created the
functions yet
and
if you think about it
so
if if a tweet is about real disasters it
might uh tag news channels and uh if you
lose
that information of news tagging the
news uh channel it could be an essential
keyword for
um predicting if tweet is about a
natural disaster or not
and so i wanted to preserve uh the word
news if it's occurring in in a tweet or
not
and that's and that's something that i
have to detect before i remove all the
mentions so this is the sin this is the
rejects for removing the mentions
from the tweets
so in the next cell
you'll find a list of functions so these
all functions
does us does their specific jobs so it
removes the urls
it removes the html entities uh what
what could have done been done is you
could refactor them into just a function
that takes in a rejects
and it
matches with the pattern and a given
text so you basically might not have to
run uh
you might not have to write so many
functions
but i i wrote them to you know have
these names in it and so that it's more
uh user-friendly and readable
for the demo so then you can convert
them into a lowercase you might actually
don't need to do that because you can
just really call that function from the
lambda functions
all these functions are created to
support uh pandas lambda functions so
what it does a
pandas apply function
yeah the url pattern is a fixed quantity
yes you fix it
uh you fix the pattern you have to
create the pattern uh so there are
different uh tutorials you can find for
uh creating regex
and uh
you will have to fix it
and pass the text for with re.sub and if
you want to replace it with something
you'll find all the urls replaced with
something and i haven't written anything
so it's just not going to put anything
over there
so you have to you have to um
for to create uh
regex you will have to go for rejects
tutorials in which you would be able to
create more red checks
so uh
so if you go to data camp if you're if
you're familiar with data camp you can
find more tutorials on rejects
and uh you can also verify to their
websites in which you can put down your
rejects and you can put a put a sample
string and it'll do the tests for you so
it's just automated online ui as opposed
to like uh
as
python code like this but it does
essentially the same job in the
background
so once i'm done with these so uh
so again here so if you see so i used re
sub and i used re find all as well so
rejects find also finding all the types
of punctuations that are appearing there
in uh the text
so counting um
um
uh for counting the punctuations and
getting a length so this basically
returns a list so get punctuation is
going to be a list of punctuation and if
you get the length of it you basically
get the number of punctuation that was
there in a text
the text that you pass in
and pre-process text basically again i
use um
the regex substitute um
form and what i see what i say here is
if you find anything apart from
uh so that
so this sign says if you find anything
apart from the alphabets digits and
spaces uh then replace them all with
basically nothing so with this null
and
uh you basically
just keep or sieve out only the texts
the numbers uh the alphabets and the
numbers out of it and the spaces so
that's the only thing that you retain in
the data set you remove everything else
and so basically you're removing all the
punctuations from here and you will be
losing information on in
on um if there are any symbols
so you have to have you have to first so
i am not using uh emoji detection in
this one
um
so if if you're uh going for emoji
detection you will have to execute the
emoji detection before you apply this
cleaning of text so you have to do it
before it so you see preprocess text is
the last thing that i do here
and i have everything else done one by
one so this is a
a pipeline sort of a thing
where you design and you prioritize
depending on what you want to keep and
what you want to remove and what
information you want to extract before
you before you remove some information
so when you remove noise you always
remove some information and you need to
pick and choose uh what information you
want to keep so if you want if you
wanted in emoticons
from the tweets then you you will have
to do it before you pre-process this
text and remove all the punctuations and
sometimes emoticons are also um
ascii values so you might if you you
might want to use uh keep that in mind
um
so
before you remove hashtags and stuff you
might have to do it before it
um
uh
so yeah so i first removed the urls than
the html entities and i
for for pandas this kind of of
um
this kind of command
you will basically so what pandas does
it iterates through every uh every text
in the tweets uh if through every tweet
in the text column
through every tweet in the text column
and it replies this function so it
automatically calls
so this could translate for each
in
a
column called text
so it basically calls remove urls
tweet
so for every so for every tweet in there
it applies remove url so you don't
really have to specify anything up out
of it over here as function which you're
basically calling this function for
every tweet
in in the column text so that i have
that is what i have done in all of these
um
executions here in this cell
and it'll take a while to to run
regex one is my favorite website to
teach you about rejects quickly with
very short interactive lessons yeah
i haven't used regex one but yeah i i
have used data camp and i think um
any of those tutorials if you start
experimenting with it it just becomes
really easy
yeah
yes um
for this use case yes right it is a
concise version of for loop and it's
also very faster so for for if you use a
for loop it's going to take a very long
time so you can try and um compare the
time you can time both of them you can
use a for loop on each of these tweets
and apply any of these functions and you
find when you time it with the apply
function you see it's going to be really
much faster
than using for loop so
[Music]
uh so then last uh we're just checking
on the training heads we have created
one extra uh feature here which is the
punctuation count per tweet
and
uh we have replaced body uh the
percentage 20 which translates to uh a
space um
and um
uh
yeah
so that's removed from the keyword
section
and then i'll do a little bit of
some some punctuation analysis here and
see uh
this is just exploring uh if there's any
pattern which is existent in the number
of punctuations which are there in real
disasters because you might think that
if you're exp if you're saying okay i'm
safe and you put in loads of
explanations when you're
posting a tweet
so it could be possible that the the
real disasters might have a higher in
higher number of punctuations
but it's clearly
opposite where on texts about which are
not about real disasters have really
many outliers so it has a it's it has a
longer distribution than real disasters
and about real disasters they're more
like concise
um
and then i checked uh so i basically
cleaned keywords did i clean the
keyboards here
so yeah cleaning the keywords here um
and then just taking a look at um
so what's like uh when i was talking
about uh text uh normalization so maybe
an example over here uh demolish
demolished and demolition they could all
um
go back into the root form which is
called demolish
so demolition is a noun and demolish is
also is a verb so
there could be um
you might have to pass in the part of
speech um information to a nematizer in
order to get that root form
and if you're using stemming
uh you might see just d e m o l i appear
and by because it is a rule-based
mechanism as opposed to um
a more advanced uh sort of machine
learning sort of um
solution it'll just uh blindly remove s
e s h e d or h e d and it'll just keep
uh d e m o l i s or maybe d e m o l i
and then what happens is uh you lose
some information over there uh because
they're not they're not real
representations of the word
but you'll still be able to you know uh
make them a standard
so um
that's about key words and
so if we want to um we want to uh see
if if a tweet is about um
natural disasters then you might want to
see uh you might see a lot of people
mentioning the casualties uh the num
some sort of numbers associated in those
uh about those disasters in the tweets
so here what i've done is i wanted to
capture if there was some sort of number
present in a tweet or not so um
and uh what i've done here is so i've
just
did a regex find all if it matches a
pattern for numbers then it gives me a
list here
and i just see if there is a list which
comes out then i
then send then i return a one
if it doesn't have any number it'll not
return anything so you just return a
zero in that case and so i constructed a
bar chart here
and it's comparing um the number of if
numbers are present or absent for uh
real disasters and are not uh tweets
about real disasters and non-virtual
disasters and if you see
in the tweets about real disasters the
percentage of uh appearance of numbers
is higher than that than those in
which are not about real disasters
um
so um
so that's about mentioning a mention of
numbers and tweets and we go into
sentiment analysis why we need to do
sentiment analysis is because um you
would you would assume you're you're
sharing
some sort of negative emotion
um
or you know saying there was a terrible
accident so
you would have a higher percentage of
you would assume that you have a higher
percentage of negative um
sentiment expressed over there as
opposed to positive sentiment
so in this in this one we're using our
spacey and you might have to download
these
depending on what your setup is
so it does take a little bit of while
let me know if your
codes have executed the first two lines
here
if you have any problem
in those
so yeah so once it's done
um what i did is so i just called so
spacey has its own
spacey and text blob these are two main
um natural language processing python
libraries
um and
spacey uh
has um has an integration with text blob
so text blob specializes
um
[Music]
i told you i'll address your question
later on right in the slack channel
maybe
thanks
um
so uh
so yeah so text blob is a python library
which specializes in understanding uh
tweets uh sentiment and it is given up
by uh the polarity of uh of a tweet so
that's the that
so
that's the uh api that gives you that
information so i what i did is applied
that and this is a lambda function so x
here represents every iteration of the
tweet over there so it's more like for
all
tweets
all tweets
which i have expressed as
x here because i've used x here
then uh
get me
all the energy
of
uh
convert x into an nlp object so nlp is
the object that you create from spacey
um and it essentially creates um
gets understands and analyzes all the
properties that uh understand the tokens
and understanding the
recognizes the named entities in it the
parts of speech tagging and you don't
have to really do any you just need to
convert the text into an nlp object from
specie
and there because they have integrated
with text blob you can just easily go
for um dot underscore on dot polarity so
you basically have to call that on it
access that that um attribute and you
get that value basically in
the in the column called sentiment
so the lambda function what it does is
it iterates through every instance
of tweets in the text column and it
applies it converts each of these tweets
into an nlp object and it accesses the
polarity attribute from that object and
basically stores for each of these
corresponding tweets into the column
called sentiment
and will take
some time to run
and then uh like i checked for location
and numbers i will check how much what
is the distribution of uh the the tweets
about the disasters uh based on the
sentiment if it's positive or negative
so now uh sentiment what the number that
you're gonna get from sentiment is a
continuous number between minus one and
one
and uh
if you can either you know you can
either binarize it so
this is how i have done it so if the if
the number that you've got gotten from
the sentiment polarity if it is more
than zero then uh make them all ones
and if it's less than zero then make
them all zeros
and you can set a threshold depending on
the use case that you're working on
sometimes because uh zero is basically
pretty much a gray area
uh where the model was not uh sure if
it's more uh positive or negative it's
more like a neutral region
so uh sometimes you might want to set a
threshold if it's 0 or 0.1 uh that you
want to uh you know set uh the binarizer
to
it takes some time and we can go back
um so is there any more questions until
it runs
no model named text spacey blob
uh
so
think you have to do
this first
can you try and do this first
all right so i
execute the binarizer and plot it around
here and
so twit tweet length analysis is again
uh if i'll just walk through what i've
done and we can stop at the data
modeling pipeline building so the tweet
length analysis for
any language text sometimes keywords is
um
an important part of analysis is
um about assessing how long or short a
text is so this is precisely what i've
done here to check how long or short the
the the texts are
in the sentiment again you can see uh
if you go back to the sentiment analysis
um
the chart
the real disasters have a higher
percentage of negative sentiment
expressed than that of positive
sentiment and you can see the same uh
for non-real disasters it basically
follows through the same um
same uh original distribution
so um
still we are in the in
this in a good line here for tweet
length analysis i have plotted here a
histogram of
the the words the number of words that
are occurring in per tweet
and the number of characters per tweet
as well so they will basically go hand
in hand because uh the
the higher the number of words the that
higher is the number of characters you
can also normalize them uh using
different um
stylometric techniques
uh
the next important thing here would be a
word clause that is uh one of the core
uh text analytics um
text analytics uh tool for data
visualization where you
where you
use uh the python library called word
cloud to create a chart like this which
contains a whole set the whole set of
words that you've been that you have in
a data set and you see how which words
occur more frequently so what i've done
here is first i have divided the data
set into two sets one which contains all
the tweets about natural disasters and
one which does not uh the tweets which
are not about real disasters
and i plotted them using the word cloud
python library
and you see what in in the in the word
clause for tweets about real disasters
the words new
fire death these are the words that are
that are of um bigger and bolder font so
these are the words that have occurred
more um number of times in the in this
set
whereas more generic terms you will find
in the words the in the tweets which are
not about real disaster so you can
fairly distinguish this this has a topic
which is which is disastrous
uh fire suicide bomber uh
you find spill emergency weapon burning
wildfire storm
these kind of words whereas this is more
like it doesn't have a specific um
doesn't have a specific topic associated
with it
um
we can
so
with the location analysis
um i what i've done is i just detected
if there's location associated with it
or not and i just plot it if there is an
identifiable location in the tweet text
body or not
i can execute it later and read the
comments here
and finally for the text data
preparation i will just be using the
location information
i'll just be using the location
information
and
um
and the and the text
uh the tokenized text and i will join
them both
and that is what we're going to be
training the uh training a model on
so
in the model training pipeline uh i'll
let these
lines these cells execute
so this is plane joining two columns
which contains textual information
that's it
you can easily do it in pandas and once
i've done that i have created a few
helper functions in this cell
which is just for
uh printing the classification metrics
and predicting that um
this is not basically required for you
because i haven't predicted on the
actual title data data set
on the actual kaggle challenge
so the
this is just for printing the
classification metrics once you pass in
the required um
[Music]
uh
the the required
arguments
which is the actuals and the predicted
um values
in the count so uh there are two ways of
using so we looked at the back of words
model and the tf idf model so for the
bag of more bag of words model you will
be using count vectorizer
and for the tf idea vectorizer you will
be using this
tf idea vectorizer from sklearn
and
yeah so the data set is all prepared you
can see
uh all text so we have all text here
and that is um basically a
tokenized version of location
information and
a text tokenized information
and then what we have to do is because
we need to pass this so this count
vectorizer always takes takes in a
string as opposed to a list so right now
you can see this is in the form of a
list
so we need to join them all back with
spaces
and that's what i've done here so all
text joined and i applied so basically
join all the elements in this list
with
including a blank space so that's all
i've done here
and then went on to create this contract
riser where i have split the data set
into a train and a test data set
um
train and test sets where i have an x
strain with which i'm going to train the
model and y train
which is the target for the training
samples
and x test and y test test correspond to
the test set of this data set and i've
split it by 20 percent so 80 percent of
the data set is result for training them
all and 20 percent of the data set as
result for testing the model
and then i used created a pipeline here
a column transformation using count
vectorizer
which is basically going to create a
matrix of all the words and the counts
of all these words in the data set
and
using that transformer i will fit it on
the x strain
which is our training samples
and
i will
after transforming basically uh the
you will create you'll get a sparse
matrix
out of it and if you see uh the shape of
it
you see uh there are 5 53 000 columns in
it so basically 53 000
almost 54 000 um features that has been
extracted that is that is the number of
words that are present in this entire
data set
and you see this is really sparse so
that is one of the drawbacks of um you
know of this um
sort of a model statistical models in
which you take the number of counts of
the vocabulary so there are different
ways of minimizing the vocabulary
and you can um i can follow it on some
um some links to go through such
tutorials
uh and once you've got this uh feature
so basically you've converted all
everything that you had in text into
numbers right now so these are all the
counts or the number of words appearing
and you basically will be passing all
this entire matrix
to
the logistic regression function
so which is a machine learning model
that i will be using for this tutorial
and for fitting it you will need this um
the the sparse matrix and the
corresponding labels or the target
values and then just
fit it
predict it and you get the predictions
on the test set so this is the data
that
um which is unseen
by the model
and this is the data which is seen by
the model
and so the training prediction and the
test predictions are stored so basically
you get a series of zeros and ones
depending on what the model thinks this
would be
and i think i did not execute this
so once i print this
so i'm basically passing on the training
predictions uh predictions on the test
date and uh
also on the training set so you see the
train if you if the model is if is if
the model is um
evaluated on them on the on the data
that it has been trained on you see the
accuracy is really high the f1 score is
also very high that means the
performance is
really good and so it's it indicates
that um
the model has been over fit or it it
it learned very um too hard from the
data has been given out
and uh you see the the performance on
the test data has is less than that
which is um
uh from the the training accuracy or the
training at one score
so
this this shows how um
how a model could overfit because of uh
statistical uh nlp techniques
um
and then
similarly i've used tf idea vectorizers
this is basically this is just the knife
um
term frequency counter and this is
normalized over all the documents
and with the same
ways i have um trained a model uh
using the extreme sparse and white
trains so this is a sparse matrix that
has been generated by transforming that
model uh transforming the text data into
its
tfidf vector form and then passing on
the labels and then predicting on the
similar form of uh logistic regression
and then
evaluating the models here
the the accuracy have gone down a little
bit
and i would i would think this is
because on the individual texts
of are really short um
short uh length so if
um and also the data set is not very
large for larger data sets tf idf is is
a better option than count vectorizer
and lastly
this is
just an experiment for helping you
out in checking different sort of models
so you can basically pass in a list of
models and you can create everything
that i've written here in python
into a specific purge function and
iterate through different models with
its default v with its default uh
parameters and see how it performs
on these uh data sets so the logistic
regression is the is the best option
here according to this report because it
has the highest number of um
highest accuracy and f1 score uh
multinomial nb is in the second position
and decision tree classifier is um
hasn't performed really well and that's
mostly because
these uh
uh these um this is a really sparse data
set and decision trees are not well
equipped to um
look at such sparse data
um so
so the performance of decision tree or
any other
ensemble methods will not be as good as
the probabilistic models like logistic
regression and multinomial envy because
counts are essentially giving um out an
an impression of the probability of the
words occurring in it in a text so these
are because so probability models are
more related to the idea of uh tf idf
and um
backup word small so hence their
performances would also be uh better
than uh ensemble methods for classifiers
all right and then there's some less of
future work and i think i'm done for the
tutorial sorry about rushing through the
entire thing you can be in touch with me
on linkedin or
um on or on the slack channel and we can
resolve some questions that we have from
this tutorial
thank you
great stuff thank you very much
uh so we just went a little bit on but i
think it was worth it was an extra 10
minutes
and thank you for enabling for that
great tutorial and well hopefully
everyone in the audience has learned a
lot
and that to be able to use this and grow
as a data scientist
uh so again just like to thank navanesha
and but also to thank you very much all
of you who attended and all of you
contributed making some really good
session we hope you enjoy the rest of
the uh conference
that's it i think i'm going to leave the
recording there we're going to have the
recording up on youtube youtube
eventually not immediately but
eventually i'm going to stop the
recording now thank you very much
everyone who's watching us on youtube
thank you